let me ask you I know where I was just
talking earlier about the Strauss and
how in the fourth turning yes do you
know John zanakis and
um and generational Dynamics no no
explain it you need to get into this guy
uh when I was uh helping Andrew
Breitbart put together
a big piece he was the first guy that I
reached out to John zanakis who has a
website called generational Dynamics
basically the Strauss and how thesis is
that
you know America has 14 of four turns
four turns and again a few seasons keeps
going different seasons of generations
so just we'll give it for people who
aren't familiar though the real quick is
you get a period of of what is it of
after a crisis there's like a great
growth then there's a period of sort of
like the high we level off then things
start to shake then you get a crisis
then it goes after the crisis things get
better again right so there's four
stages and if you go back from now like
80 years you had World War II before the
Civil War before that you had the
Revolutionary cycle of approximately 80
years so we are in the fourth turning
right now right so anyway continue
anyway yeah yeah so I mean real quick
sorry which means we should be expecting
a very serious crisis on the scale of
War within the next seven years right a
generational crisis period right yeah so
I mean it's not it's not new it's he's
taking the cycle of regimes and he's
compressing it
and you know and looking at a different
way anyway what zanakis was doing was
he's applying this to International
affairs
so if you're looking at like America is
following along one particular rotation
let's say you've got let's say you're
talking about America and England
has its own rotation right Iraq has its
own rotation so it enables you to um to
predict what is going to happen
in war and and in these things well no I
mean it's it's a methodology more than a
um
uh you know more than a particular
I think I think there's going to be a
collapse
um if you look at
this this draws how generational Theory
whether it's true or not I mean maybe
it's just a coincidence that we've had
these periods and and often you know uh
people point out like what about Korean
War about Vietnam what about you know
Iraq Afghanistan where do these fit into
these theories and things like that
so so maybe it'll happen maybe it won't
but I do see
when you have the Democrats lying and it
is Relentless it is a zombie horde
they'd never stop there's no break
there's no calm there's no peace there's
no compromise
and the best part is they wield the
propaganda machines in the big Tech
establishment to claim it's the
Republicans who are doing that when the
Republicans are sleeping on the job
so what happens is I sit here every day
at best they're sleeping in the job yeah
some of them are just absent so I sit
here every day watching the news and I'm
like here we go again the Democrats are
lying about everything and the
Republicans have some of them are
agreeing with the Democrats and the rest
of them are just sitting there acting
like speed bumps so you watch them you
watch the Empire taking control and I
really want to stress a point I've been
making all week when people would say
how did Nazi Germany get so bad where
everybody's doing the Roman salute
people in this country for the past year
have been doing the red salute on
marches in the thousands defying the
edicts of the governors in which
conservatives got arrested because they
were defying the mandates yet these red
soluting extremists and regular people
who joined in get a pass they didn't
wear masks they didn't lock down and
nothing was done about it and when you
look at New York what did de Blasio say
Well they're allowed to do that but what
happened when the conservatives stood on
the steps of the Michigan State House
waving a little Gadsden flag terrorism
attack yeah
they're not gonna be careful because the
people doing the red salute could be if
you look at World War II metaphor the
Communists that they developed the Nazi
party to counter so we got to be careful
that we don't end up creating a movement
to counter this woke mob that ends up
becoming the dangerous I don't think
there's anything you can do about it no
what do you mean of course we can no
creating it as we go no see what happens
is there's a for every action there's an
equal and opposite reaction when you get
thousands of people marching through the
streets doing the red salute don't be
surprised when you get a counter force
it is you can't do you have you'll have
energetically equal response but the way
it manifests is up to us it could be
violent it could be peaceful
it could be organized it could be
chaotic it's going to be the exact same
thing I don't think so it it shows
itself in different ways it might be
another party like you saw the proud
boys kind of but that that floundered
more or less I don't know they got
crushed by the state yeah and antifa is
protected by anything anything that
comes up by the from the right that
looks anything like antifa is going to
be crushed yeah they don't want another
name that's what that's exactly what
January says
that's what it's about it's in order to
stop that and frankly it's in order to
to stop any more rallies right
I mean people are afraid to have rallies
you have a rally and they're going to
make the claim January 6 January 6th so
no yep correct and and they have I mean
part of you know in my in my kind of
past life I was doing uh terrorism
analysis and um you know so I'm kind of
intimately familiar with what they're
about to do to us here which is
um you know they've already they've
already created these absurd metrics
they've already created
um you know ideological screens and
tasks for who is a terrorist and all of
us here frankly
you know fall under it oh yeah and um
you know and and and and this is how
they will justify I mean you know this
is how they will justify using social
media companies right to go after us you
know financial institutions things like
that so it's it's better it's very bad
you look you look back at history and
you can see the assassination plots
against uh certain you know
to according to the government the
undesirable figures the activists who
are leading the charges for social
change and stuff so they should have
killed people but at certain point they
realized you create Martyrs you make
people Immortal then we see Julian
Assange what do they do to him
characters keep them in a box character
assassination destroy his legacy now the
left that used to love the man hate the
man they despise him he's a he's a
rapist it's not true that's read the
news it's all clearly fake and made up
and then lock him in a box and let him
slowly die a slow and miserable death
Julian Assange did a bunch of really
great work exposing a lot of the
corruption and so they figured out the
best way to deal with them is to make
sure he'll never be a martyr don't let
him die let him slowly rot away and lose
his mental faculties and then accuse him
of extremely heinous crime so that
people are scared to say they support
him and that's what's in store for
everybody else but it also means that
there's not going to be trains they're
not going to round people up that's not
going to happen what's going to happen
is they're going to shut off your credit
card and then you're gonna starve and
then they're gonna say well but it's a
private company oh but you know go use
your US dollars go buy oh but the store
doesn't take cash well that's too bad
you should maybe you shouldn't be a
bigot bigot my friend just lost her
PayPal why she has no idea
gone yep you know she's public and on
the right
it could be anything yeah and uh you
know take away your access to banking
which they've done to the proud boys
they've done to a bunch of groups
it's amazing uh it's happening and it's
getting worse every day what did they
say yesterday gradually and then
suddenly someone said in the super chats
yeah and it's and it's remarkable that's
my line it comes from Hemingway yeah
it's how do you go broke yep gradually
and then suddenly from a Movable Feast
so what we have now is uh I think I I
don't think it's a
the night is always darkest for the dawn
but I don't think it's completely
hopeless I think what will happen is
there will be a collapse I think the
states will split apart I think Florida
Ron DeSantis is floor I know people who
if I if I have a friend who's moving you
know they're moving to Texas or Florida
sure yep and I'm like come on West
Virginia what are you doing good look
Johnny how do you compete with action
though you know how do you compete with
uh with the with the beach it's very
hard yeah but the weather it's so humid
it's so hot it's like 10 000 degrees
literally like I swear I saw someone
just like burst into flame spontaneously
combust once when I was in Miami and I'm
like I had to run run to shade as like
have you seen um the have you seen the
core where they go to the Center of the
Earth to reset the core there's a scene
where like oh so it's a documentary yeah
there's a scene where like because the
magnetosphere is weak solar microwaves
beam through and it's like this beam is
just melting like the Golden Gate Bridge
and it's collapsing because it's so hot
that's like Miami it's like that like
you're just walking on the beach you see
like that everyone runs from the from
the Sun and people are just being melted
and no it's not that bad but they're
going to Florida and Texas because of
the laws because Florida and Texas are
actually protecting individual rights
and resisting all this stuff
you look at these blue States
that's bad and what's really bad is the
stuff we're talking about with the cult
it's blue States putting in people to
Federal level who then exert authority
over red States
makes no sense
or like somebody in West Virginia wants
to go hunt feral Hogs with their with
their buddy down the street and they
lend him a gun it's fine not in the blue
States I don't I think that we've been
negligent about a lot of things but
about a lot of local politics in in this
country
um we have this every four years we have
this big nonsense going on in Washington
DC about who gets to be the president
we've got big nonsense every two years
about Congress
etc etc nobody knows who their Senator
or you know people know maybe who their
Senator is nobody knows who their
representative is nobody knows who the
mayor is etc etc we need we in red
States need to slow down and get into
this yes local yes all the way people
ask me oh you know do you think so and
so will be you know we'll run for the
house who cares I don't care you know
what really bothered me a lot of
Republicans did this too they were like
my you know our district is bad and if
you vote for me I'll fix the district
and I'm like no you won't because you're
a federal politician the person was
going to fix the district is the
aldermen or the or the local state
senator or State Rep the the person
running for congress is going to go to
the federal government to represent your
District to the federal government
they're going to be voting on war not
voting on whether or not to clip the
trash in your neighborhood but they all
run on this yep what do they say like
I'll get money Federal money for you
it's often vague it's like if you look
at our district you can see how bad
things have gotten with crime On The
Rise and I'm like I don't care you don't
represent those problems the local
politicians do you're going to go to DC
and they're going to ask you should we
bomb this country and you're
representing this District as to whether
or not we bomb the country and they're
going to vote Yes I think the nice thing
about the internet is that you can do
the local politics and show the world
how it's done with internet video and
then they can emulate it so you kind of
create a decentralized organization
organizational you know pattern where
where we can make a really cool YouTube
show about what it's like to run local
government I got in the next city will
be like I want to do that too and then
all over the world at once I've got a
solution
I've got a solution to all of our
political problems I call it marsism yes
and we need Elon Musk to help create
this new form of government it's very
simple
every time someone runs for office at
the federal level and wins they go on to
a ship which sends them to Mars
that's it that's it
that's a long commute to work no no just
go to Mars they just go we just we just
move the government no the government
the individuals who win it's like Yay
again
what if it's better on Mars that's great
good for them they'll have a good time
right and then we won't have them to to
bug us I guess that's true I guess
that's I guess that's true Nancy Pelosi
you've won for the 30th time here's your
rocket ship thank you Elon
and then she gets in and it's like you
know we do we go to the teachers unions
first oh yeah yeah we we put the that
would be fun the Capitol Building I got
an idea this January 6th thing it's real
bad all right these people there's this
Insurrection I know how to prevent it
have the Capitol Building be on Mars
boom send all those people to Mars and
they can talk amongst themselves and
vote how they so choose and uh they'll
never have to worry about an
Insurrection ever again
reasonable
it's all right about that we need new
industry that we need new Banking and
new social media
um like I think I see like a
government-free software social media
service that's like based on the First
Amendment the Constitution and like a
banking system like on the blockchain
like do it a local level Florida should
make it yeah no joke everybody isolate
it everybody has a role to play think
about think about this you know um
Donald Trump received how many votes in
2020. like
74.74 that's about the population of
France
it's more than Francis right so France
like 60. so how many sure how many
businesses provide things for the French
consumer
a lot this is a big Market I mean it's
not a small number of people Texas
Florida here's what you do you pass a
bill right now that will create a
Florida Social Network boom
look Hungary just did this yeah they
just created their own social network
that is familiar to Facebook right
um and uh you know but but it's it's
it's just trying to get off the ground
but you're going to need this type of
thing yep you're going to need this type
people wouldn't use it right but but
here I guess the problem is Trump had
the opportunity to change the game and
he decided not to exactly exactly Trump
needed to do one thing
Trump could have went on gab and said hi
yep and that would have been a shock
wave I think about that with myself too
I use Twitter often and I'm like why did
I just post on that it's not that it's
that Trump no it's commanded the news
correct exactly and so if Trump said if
Trump went on parlor gab or mines or any
platform and said I am going to send a
spaceship to the moon the media would be
forced to report on you know gas Donald
Trump said this and the reporters would
be forced to sign up to follow him and
Trump would not do it and I guess it was
because Jared Kushner who was just like
man don't do it Donald don't don't
change don't take the power away from
Silicon Valley I'm not sure that that
was the case I mean the reporting was
that Trump wanted to use parlor and
Kushner said not to
so I don't know maybe it's not true I
don't I don't know I mean I would love
to know the the ins and outs of that but
but absolutely it's absolutely
inexcusable what he did and this is why
I think I think DeSantis should run in
2024 not Trump and I wonder where is
Trump Jr to go go to his dad and be like
Dad get on gab like right now
isn't it too late oh it's way too late
it's wait it's weird and not only is
that instead of doing any of that he
could he could still do it it wouldn't
matter as much he just makes his own
website
talk about somebody cringe who just
exactly absolutely cringe so it's it's
unfortunate that was the best the
anti-establishment had had to offer but
look but but this was this was a problem
throughout the Trump years which was
that he consistently empowered I mean
look you're the president of the United
States you can say I'm going to talk to
whoever you know whichever media Outlet
I want and in so doing you will Elevate
this Outlet who did he go to he talks he
talked to uh to New York Times
Yes you know yeah Haberman he was on the
phone with her all hours the night you
know it was reported like you know I'm
sorry call the Federalist call The Daily
Caller you know yeah uh there's because
there's no law that says the New York
Times And The Washington Post need to
have access it's because Republicans
Trump included care more about what the
New York Times thinks about them than
their own constituents maybe not so much
for Trump but for the Republicans yes
so the New York Times comes out and says
you know this politician look at Ted
Cruz right when he went on vacation and
then he flew back because the media was
yelling at him
that's so that's so lame
I liked I like Ted Cruz so I'll take
that one back but uh it was pathetic it
was one of the most pathetics like
having a cared and crappy I would I
would if I if I wanted vacation during a
storm or whatever and the media got mad
I'd get a cigar what are those what are
those things called where you clip the
cigar with it you know what I mean
Clipper Clipper I don't know anything
but you know I get one anyway I get like
a velvet or or a smoking jackets no no
no no like a robe a rope yeah okay yeah
and then I I turned a video on while I'm
in whatever place I put my feet up I
clip the cigar and light it
and that's it
well look that's I've added media that's
how you have to do it because you need
to give them at least at least as much
contempt as they give you
just stop bending the knee thanks for
checking out this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time